welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and her guest
is Claudia vallega who is a biological
anthropologist at Yale she studies the
interactions between human reproductive
biology and the ecological and cultural
context in which it develops her
research interests include human
reproductive ecology Reproductive
Endocrinology maternal and child health
evolutionary demography and bio
demography of aging today we'll talk
with Professor Valeria about the health
of indigenous peoples
welcome professor Falacci thank you very
much Marilee it's been a pleasure okay
so you have a paper that you co-authored
with Josh Snodgrass that is in the
annual review of anthropology where
you're looking at indigenous populations
worldwide so let's talk about a little
Matt a little bit give us an overview of
the paper the paper came out a couple of
years ago and it's an overview of the
situation of the health and well-being
of indigenous people across the globe
okay and are you looking in particular
countries not particular in this and
what we attempted to do a global Oliver
II although my experiences with the
Americas okay so go ahead and it is an
important line of research both Josh and
I have been working with indigenous
populations for the last 20 years and
wanted to bring to the front the
predicament of indigenous peoples
nowadays and the challenges they face
economically socially politically
emotionally as they transition to
different lifestyles and how that has an
impact on their health
okay let's define the term indigenous
because I know there's some politics
around that of course yeah the term in
it's loaded as you may imagine socially
and politically so we cannot really talk
off a definition there's always going to
be criticism based on different
perspectives for our papers we used one
that refers to certain criteria for
defining the groups that have lived in a
particular geographical area over a long
period of time pre-colonization and
pre-invasion from other societies and
that had a continuity over time in that
region so that that is more a criteria
definition there are also referential or
relational definitions that put the
group the population in relation to
other groups in that geographical area
and those are good definitions - they
serve other purposes and many times
they're more nuanced because they
highlight the relationship between the
indigenous group and hegemonic powers or
other social political powers with which
they interact
okay so let's talk about specific
indigenous peoples that you did look at
yes so I've been working for the last 20
years with the calm of Argentina and I'm
gonna make an aside because in the
literature you will find that they're
called Toba tota but for the last five
six years there is a strong movement to
towards changing their name to come
which is the name they referred to
themselves writings our people towba was
termed that other indigenous people used
to refer to them and in in warren ET
this language means big forehead because
they had a cultural practice of shaving
their the first few centimetres of their
hair so they looked like they had big
foreheads okay so these people inhabit
the gran chaco area of south america
which is no
northern Argentina southern Paraguay a
little bit of Brazil and a little bit of
Bolivia and originally hunter-gatherers
have been one of the last indigenous
populations in Argentina to be settled
and colonized and I also work with
Iguchi which is another a different
linguistic family from the calm but who
share the same territory the current
Chaco okay any other outside of the
Americas at America out south of South
America I've been working with cattle
and to to heal Maya people of Guatemala
okay
so in terms of your paper what are some
of the changes that are significantly
impacting the indigenous peoples yeah of
the places that you've looked at across
the world what you see is a process of
westernization or in some cases
globalization so changes important
changes in their lifestyle that comes
from encroachment of settled settlers
from different parts of the country
where they live
- Frank colonization and this may have
happened a couple of centuries ago or
very recently like some Amazonian
populations who are still not they have
been contacted they have been
interacting somehow with a Western world
but they are still living in their
traditional lifestyle so we see spectrum
of transitions the most important ones I
think our subsistence patterns
indigenous populations generally are
either hunter-gatherers or herders
pastoralists or foragers in in general
and now and with some nammed ISM some
changing in in their settling powder so
now they become settled they change
their diet they change their physical
activity patterns there is a loss of
land
cultural continuity so that that has a
definite impact on their health okay so
what about in the cultures that you've
looked at or the people that you've
looked at let's talk about some of the
health challenges that they're facing
and why right in general from Siberia to
the equator what you see is that one of
them most important health challenges is
to cope with infectious disease so
that's still pretty much the main source
of mortality gastrointestinal infections
with parasites and other pathogens
respiratory infections still taking big
toll on their lives and but now as they
become more westernized in their
lifestyle other disease are starting to
really be a problem for them like
cardiovascular disease for example and
this is related to overweight and
obesity that are affecting both
developing and developed countries right
we used to call them diseases of
affluence because they come with them
attached to an overflow of calories and
little physical activity but now it's
quite spread and you see that so while
they're getting the diseases of the
Western world they're not necessarily
getting the medical attention that the
Western world has exactly so there are
several barriers there are still a lot
of consequences of colonization
processes oppression and violence that
have an impact on their access access to
to public health services for example
when and they are available in the
countries where they live their barriers
that come with being discriminated
against by the hegemonic powers or
physical barriers some of these
populations live isolated in the middle
of the forest or in the Siberian steppes
so their their physical obstacles to
reach to free healthcare services for
example but once they get there they
maybe get discriminated language is
another barrier mostly genus people
still have their native language as the
main way of communication so there is
frustration on both parts the health
care providers and the recipients not
being able to communicate their needs
and concerns in terms of I'm curious
because you did mention that some of
them are very based in very remote areas
mm-hmm how does the Western world I'll
call it the Western world get to the
remote location and and are they are
they excited by the prospects of what
the Western world brings or are they you
know are they hesitant to embrace that's
a very good question there's a lot of
variation there is a set of populations
that are proactively seeking the contact
and the immersion in the more
westernized world and others are
completely reluctant and do not want to
get contacted as they become more and
more isolated there is a lot of pressure
for them because if they get sick or as
their territory gets smaller and smaller
they need to look for resources which
are outside of their traditional land
and that brings conflict so for them is
a push-pull situation with that so what
are some of your findings in the paper
on that in the paper we have a set of
challenges that have to do with
nutrition they have to do with
cardiovascular disease some important
and neglected areas have to do with
mental health
and psycho mode emotional well-being I'm
particularly worried about that because
we have not paid a lot of attention to
that we started exploring more
systematically that among the come and
one of the main difficulties is trying
to understand their own mental health
construct because maybe we are applying
a depression scale that works very well
in our society but it doesn't register
with them
right so we need to start a dialogue and
see that there are other ways of knowing
other ways of coping and they may be
different concerns for them that affect
their mental health indigenous people
have one of the highest rates of what we
Westerners would consider depression
anxiety suicide rates substance abuse
all reflective of this imbalance in
their well-being that in a sense we
brought to them because they they I
always used the phrase they lost their
GPS socially they need to relearn the
codes and that is that is difficult
right right especially anytime there's a
great change it is easy to lose your
moorings so great I think one of the
things that has has been happening over
the last decade is and you note this in
your paper there are more global health
initiatives
yeah of being instituted across
universities you know basically in the
north and so let's talk a little bit
about you know your findings around that
right so we have this global health
initiatives all the way from big
institution in the decisions like WD toe
down to universities in the north for
example I think every major university
here in the United States has a global
health initiative program that whose
goal is to expose students to other
realities in
terms of health and illness which are
very good and well intended goals but
there are certain issues that have to be
adjusted when is taken to the most of
them developing countries such as well I
might my take is that sometimes we are
reproducing colonial ways in what way we
are sending students to this developing
country setting to get trained in global
health so that is basically colonial
perspective I'm not saying that every
single one has but it's something that I
urge global health programs to be aware
of and to do some self-reflection in the
kind of attitude students go to there is
the typical savior syndrome right I know
what it takes to get help these pick up
these people right well it's just the
opposite we are there to learn right we
are there to learn about other ways of
knowing other ways of health ill illness
the academies or the spectrum of
healthiness so I I am critical in that
sense that we need to be aware of the
pitfalls of reproducing colonial plans
do you think there are any pros to
having the Global Health Initiative
absolutely absolutely I don't want right
to stress only the negative of course
the first thing that comes to mind is
resources we can provide the material
resources the logistical resources and
some of the administrative resources
that sometimes are lacking in those
settings so we provide that capital in a
sense but we need to partner with the
local administrators and
people the indigenous people to make
this work do you think that by having
the global health initiatives and and
other services go into these communities
that they're basically helping to erode
the indigenous peoples around the world
basically by having this influence come
in it's really changing the dynamics and
they're not going to be indigenous any
longer what are your thoughts about that
that's a great question I think there's
a little bit of both in that sense that
yes we are exporting our ways of dealing
with health and dealing with disease
that may be completely different from
the indigenous peoples ways of doing it
so now the indigenous people are found
in this situation where they have to
choose with which therapeutic eating
area they will take a many time that
causes conflict among the calm for
example when a child is sick the mother
looks at the general appearance of the
child and decides whether this is a
white disease or it is something that
has to do with witchcraft so she decides
which therapeutic route to go and which
is in itself very interesting and I
think those are the things that the
Western public health system need to
understand too in order to be more
effective and really work with a
community do you ever find yourself in a
situation when you're in the field
particularly around a health concern and
perhaps this hasn't happened to you but
I am just curious you're talking about
health where you come across a situation
where the person can definitely benefit
from Western medicine but they're not
going that route oh yeah absolutely yes
so how to deal with that with a lot of
doubt many times during my years working
with a calm
I found myself in suspended belief and
say well I'm not gonna bring my own way
of thinking here because I need to
listen to and have a very particular
case and I don't know what to tell you
so I became very good friends with Betty
there is a 40 47 year old woman with
four children our worlds cannot be more
apart but somehow there was a connection
and we became friends one day I was
doing the salmon one of my trips there I
find that she's very sick
so she says I'm not sure what this is
and say Betty please come to the
hospital with me so I take it to a
hospital she goes strained into the ICU
so her state was quite delicate two days
into the EC RUC and so they look at her
said we don't know what she has
everything seems to be out of balance we
we cannot find a cause so I go to hell
so Betty God what do you think what's
going on I say well yeah this is not a
white disease take me out of here I'm
gonna die tomorrow if you don't and say
but here you are
well taking care of all your yeah your
needs are covered I'm gonna die tomorrow
Claudia take me out so I had to talk to
them that they adopted Western doctors
and say I'm taking her out and they say
well you have to sign responsibility
because this is not medically advise
sure and it was quite a moment for me to
take a decision and say well help you
just let go of my Western training I'm
trust that she knows and I did the
following day she was up and walking
really yes so can you
why can you say why again I suspended my
belief my post hoc interpretation is
that there is a big impact of feeling I
I am the
target of witchcraft which raises
cortisol levels which raises a lot of
psycho emotional stress that may affect
certain parts of your body and but
that's so did Betty believe she was a
target of which oh absolutely
she said I'm gonna go to my doctor she
did the following week she came with
little stones the the Shaymin took out
of her lungs to prove yeah you you were
the target of witchcraft
she took stones out of her lungs yes how
does that even happen I don't know you
had never way better
aha last summer I was very close to
because they invited me to go and I felt
do I belong here I don't want to intrude
say no no we want you to say because we
want you to ability this is right that
this is real right and then the
encounter never happened so maybe next
well I think yes if you get another
opportunity yeah absolutely just an
amazing yeah to be a part of so that
teaches us that we Westerners are not
the ones with the truth for everything
right so yeah other ways of there
certainly are dealing with disease okay
so what do you conclude in the paper I
well I conclude in the paper just giving
a little bit of praise to
anthropologists because I think we are
in an ideal position to collaborate in
global health initiatives and in trying
to ameliorate the the dire situation of
indigenous peoples we can act as brokers
we usually know the codes very well we
can translate the the dialogue back and
forth between the community and the
health care providers to make it more
real I'm not so top-down right right
do you see that happening in any of the
communities that you got it yeah
I have colleagues that have made of this
a career goal the issues that is not
incentivized because funding agents
agencies do not find your
community-based research applied
research in so they are interested
mostly in the science in the PD me ology
of that but doing this brokerage is not
compensated so that puts barriers in
what you can do how how would one
advocate for that to become a part of
the process I think by lobbying with
funding agents agencies like NIH and
itself saying this is important this is
broader impact I think NSF is really pay
attention to the broader impacts of
research not just the science of it and
I think as a faculty my my duty part of
my responsibility is to train my
students in having both a basic science
and an applied component in their
research and training them to become
part of the community in the sense of
you are we have the privilege you have a
voice just use it on behalf of the
indigenous people you are working with
okay so what are you working on now now
we are working on a long term project
that looks at three transitions babies
that are transitioning from being
exclusively breastfed to being on the
adult diet the puberty transition in
girls and they perimenopausal transition
in women so we are looking at physical
changes hormonal changes but also social
and cultural changes across those three
periods and transitions and trying to
understand how they talk to each other
how things get under the skin
and if we can learn from that
interaction all right well we will look
forward to hearing more from you thank
you very much thank you for the
opportunity to discuss my research okay
for more information about professor of
allergy and her research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
thank you
you